Toward the end of his life Martin Luther
King was surrounded by the forces of
both chaos and community. The chaos of
Jim Crow America the chaos of white
supremacy and unfairness in the
workplace but he was also surrounded by
the community of the black freedom
struggle. This remains with us today. We
are surrounded by the chaos of forces
that are trying to pull us back to
another time in American history but
we're also full of community and the
communities that are waging struggles to
actually advance human dignity and human
freedom and liberation. At the Ralph
Bunche Center for after American Studies
we walk hand-in-hand with the struggles
to advance humanity and community.
What we're doing is we're using the research of the university to look at questions
of employment for African Americans and
questions of how the prison system has
impacted black families and black
communities. We invite you to join us in
this work this research and in the
struggle.